hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
saint anselm's treatise on truth the day
veritate ranges over a number of
different truth-related topics in its 13
chapters ultimately the goal is going to
be surveying the various types of truth
and showing
that they all
however diverse they are
are contained in one unity of truth but
we should begin
by looking
not at the unity but at the plurality
the multiplicity the types of
modes of truth and
this in fact seems to resist the idea of
providing a definition of truth but as
we'll find out that's not really the
case so in the very first chapter
there's an invocation of one of anselm's
earlier works the monologian and the
student says i think you gave a
definition of truth there and anselm
says no no i didn't give you any sort of
definition and he uses the word
definitio there of truth but you know
maybe we could find one and what would
be the strategy
for
finding a definition of truth is it
let's start out at the really high level
of abstraction and then come down or is
it let's do this socratic style throw
out a definition and then i'll knock it
to pieces
no anselm says let's do something
different
let's survey
the
different kinds of things in which we
say
that there is truth and this is a very
important thing to point out so
different things as it's often
translated is diversitas right a
diversity
a
literally going away turning away from
each other although we're gonna have to
bring them back in together and it's
attentiveness to how do we actually
use our language how do we actually
think about these things let's not
put aside
various kinds of truth because we
approach it with some ready-made theory
like well the correspondence theory of
truth or the coherence theory of truth
says blah blah blah blah
instead let's see what we actually
say truth exists in
or
in which there is truth we could say
and so he begins by looking at the you
know
long customary by that time
area of we could say language or
signification and you know he's going to
stress uh throughout the work that this
could be any kind of signification it
could be written it could be spoken it
could be other kinds of signs so truth
in signification in
signification the chapter title and then
he talks about
enuntazio and these are being used more
or less anonymously the things that we
say are they true or not and anselm and
his
student uh you know come to the realize
that there's actually two different
kinds
of truth in
enunciation and this is going to be a
really important aspect of anselm's
theory about truth that's going to run
through the rest of these things as well
there's truth in the sense of the
correspondence theory something is true
when it accurately represents the state
of affairs that it's talking about so if
i say that i am a young man 20 years old
that's a false statement why is it false
because i'm no longer 20 years old i'm
at the time that i'm recording this 51
years old right if i say i'm 51 years
old that's that's true
until i turn 52 which you know will be
happening
oh
roughly
half a year from now right
so that's one kind of truth
ansem also thinks
that there is a
another kind of truth more bedrock
encoded into
language itself the truth of the
terms
and we'll go into that a little bit more
but that provides a framework for the
kind of truth or falsity that we can
find in statements that can either be
true or or false right
then
again nothing really controversial about
this we have truth in
thought and
again the chapter title and the language
being used there is a little bit of
diversity
truth in opinio you know in our
judgments or opinions about things what
we think about things and then uh
kogitazio are our thinking our
cognitions
of things as well
and we can say well this is very similar
to language right you know language uh
is what we speak out or write or
something like that we have something
kind of like a language in our head in
our thinking obviously it's not
totally linguistic there's images in
there as well and you know there's more
to it than just thought is a language
just not being communicated out loud
but you know that's pretty
straightforward as well again nothing
really new or controversial there
then we get to something that is quite
interesting
and
here we get into what you know for
example aristotle might have called
practical truth as he does in nico
mccann ethics book six although
aristotle doesn't have the concept of
the will
he does have the concept of desire and
action and so the chapters about that in
anselm they're not aristotelian but
they're dealing with similar territory
anselm says that there is also truth
in the human will in the voluntas and
it's important to keep in mind here
that for anselm the will is not just
what you happen to choose right now or
right now right it's not just
making an option between two things it's
a faculty it's a part of us it's
actually the very core of who we are and
the will itself as his later works are
going to analyze is quite complex
there is the will as use particular
volitions there is the will as faculty
or instrument there is the will as
effective or disposition or inclination
there is the will also as turning which
might you know conversion which might
apply to several of these and so there
can be truth in the will what determines
when there is truth in the will when the
will
is willing what it should or when the
will is doing what it ought to what it
was made to do and this is similar to
truth in signification and thought
there's a
what it was made for
sort of encoded or built into it and
there's a great possibility for us human
beings to go quite astray with us and to
introduce falsity
of a sort
a lack of truth
a denial of truth
into our very wills themselves
similarly action itself axio
can be judged as true or false not just
as good or bad not just as right or
wrong
but as true or false when we do
what it is that we ought to that is true
action when we
go go and do something else you know
when we do the opposite of what we ought
to do that that's false action
interestingly there's also as a later
chapter uh focuses on there's a
connection between action and
signification because action isn't just
being judged in accordance with some
standard of what you ought to do or the
will that's motivating it
every action is significative every
action
is a way for the person acting
on some level to say
this is what i ought to be doing and
therefore this is what human beings
ought to be doing so this is a very very
important correlation between the two of
them so now we've covered quite a lot of
ground what about the senses this is
something where we often talk about
truth and falsity so anselm says you
know consider the
crooked stick you know it's crooked in
the water you pull it out it's straight
what's going on there or you see a
statue of a dragon and the immature
child thinks that it's a real dragon and
gets all scared
there's a falsity there isn't there the
senses are deceiving us and anselm says
oh no no no the senses are not deceiving
you the senses are just reporting
what it is that they have to report
as a matter of fact don't don't get on
the poor little senses because you know
where the the falsity is is in
opinio in your judgment about what it is
that the senses are
telling you so you know uh the senses
and thought
are also connected together right and
then uh we have one more
uh you know set of things that's
starting to get much more metaphysical
here so we've got all these things that
are you know of the human being now we
have
truth in the very
being the essencia
of things essentia
in latin
and this is not yet the divine truth
or the supreme truth that is god
that is going to unify all the other
truths but anselm says
in things being as they are there is
already another
sort of truth and it's sort of implied
that all these other types of truth
in a way
are involving the the
truth or in the being of things and then
finally we get to the supreme truth as
it's going to turn out by the very end
of it truth is not just in these things
but truth is also one
and is indeed the supreme truth that is
god and all other truths are in a
certain sense within
god which is kind of a mind-blowing idea
that we'll talk about in greater detail
elsewhere and this eventually gets
anselm to the point of being able to
provide
a definition of truth and it's a very
interesting
definition that will be considered by
later thinkers like for example thomas
aquinas
who mentions anselm quite a bit in his
discussions of truth so how can we
define truth what connects all these
things together
it is rightness or
rectatudo this is really central to
anselm's idea rightness and
signification rightness and thought
rightness and the will rightness and
action rightness
not so much in the senses but in the
judgments about them rightness in the
being of things and the supreme
rectitude or rightness that is god
rightness that is perceptible
per capita beliefs right
can be registered can be apprehended by
what
just by the mind alone
the the senses aren't really registering
truth the senses are registering what it
is that they perceive it is the mind
that perceives things truly or falsely
and it is also the mind that judges its
own perceptions as true or
false or its willings or its actions
right so
truth according to anselm there is a
definition of it possible uh it is
rightness perceptible by the mind alone
but then it's it it's registered or
manifested in all of these
different
modes or manners all of which are
important none of which we want to leave
out
in developing an adequate
i won't say theory as such but an
adequate
understanding of what it is
that truth is
you